that's not bestiality I'm not talking
well it is bestiality but in my world
it's like you can actually make love to
an animal so what animal would it be for
you know you know answer that one no I
would be a penguin just thrown it out
there what's up everybody I'm Krista
Stefano duh welcome to stupid questions
it's stand-up month that's why I'm in a
tuxedo in a limo with Roy Wood jr. RW
jr. and he's got a special later tonight
called Noah loves you Frank and it's
great it's right and I love you know you
don't
well I've masturbated to you ok well
that counts why don't you name it no one
loves you I made my special no one loves
you because I think we live in a time
where people still think that everyone
gives a damn about you gasps no one
cares I am so happy to hear someone else
you realize that the better off you'll
be you know it is - everybody hides
behind their social media wall it's like
we got to start punching people in the
face again when's the last time you saw
somebody was just lay down don't punch
people please please don't don't what
was the hardest thing to figure out for
your special the order of the material
talk a little bit about protests and
police reform and boycotts so figuring
out what's the most poignant thing
versus what's the funniest thing and I
opened with the national anthem and how
to solve kneeling do the Kaepernick set
yeah sprinkle a little bit of that in
which I'm thankful for because you know
it's still timely by the way white
people please keep calling the police on
black people so that my special stays
relevant
would you rather piss yourself in public
once or your pants
in private daily I almost my pants
onstage once what do tell I was playing
in the comedy club in Louisville there's
this spot in the parking lot that sells
chili spaghetti chili spaghetti does not
go with with whiskey I get on stage and
I'm in a 50 this is a
fifteen minute contract yeah somewhere
around minute 35 good night folks that's
my time and I went into the bathroom and
I took the fastest speed you've
ever record go back into the showroom in
the fcc's he goes yeah well savour Roy
and he made it totally seem like an
encore when the truth of the matter was
I was getting ready to my pants
onstage in Louisville Kentucky there it
is always with me man
stupid questions you get a stupid gift
so you know your big Chicago Cubs fan
you did your special in Chicago but
you're from Alabama so nothing makes
sense but anywho I got you for your
stupid gift of Chicago deep-dish yeah
this came direct from Chicago so it's a
little cold and I got it a couple of
days ago and yeah yeah I appreciate that
there you go man it's on yeah basil I
think we'll just close that out another
place oh yeah that'd be great
oh my dude I'd ready chili spaghetti
you